en russie plus de 9000 la contamination
ont été enregistrés hier le pays a
dépassé le seuil des 400 mille cas de
malades ducobu 19
pourtant le taux de mortalité reste
faible comparé à d'autres pays 140
membres hier du côté de moscou commence
aujourd'hui le déconfinement ont fait le
point tout de suite avec notre
correspondant sur que la centaine
claireaux où il ne peut pas encore
véritablement parler de déconfinement à
l'heure actuelle à moscou mais plutôt
d'un assouplissement des restrictions
actuellement en vigueur les commerces
même non alimentaires rouvrent leurs
portes ainsi que les parcs mais les
cafés et restaurants et autres cinémas
eux restent bel et bien fermé depuis la
fin mars les moscovites ne sont
autorisés à sortir de chez eux que pour
faire leurs courses promener leur chien
ou encore descendre les poubelles
dorénavant ils pourront de nouveau
prendre l'air sans raison particulière
et ce jusqu'à trois fois par semaine
mais pour éviter que trop de monde ne se
retrouve dans la rue au même moment des
jours et des horaires de sorties ont été
établis pour chaque immeuble et pour
chaque maison de la capitale le maire de
moscou sergueï sobianine a fait savoir
que qu'il s'agissait de mesures test qui
pourrait durer entre une et deux
semaines sachant que les autorités
feront tout ce qui est en leur pouvoir
pour lever ces restrictions d'ici le 24
juin prochain date de la grande parade
militaire initialement prévue le 9 mai
dernier sur le front sanitaires même si
le nombre de nouveaux cas quotidiens
restent élevés il est toutefois moins
important qu'au début du mois de mai un
chiffre pour illustrer cette tendance le
nombre d'hospitalisations a chuté de 40%
depuis le 12 mai dernier